right the article i mean this is public
information you bought people's piece
for 777 thousand dollars right yeah
bro now that [ __ ] my pen that is
literally putting money put putting your
mouth or your money where your mouth is
it's like that what kind of money is
insane yeah this is mine yeah to the
average person that's a lot of yeah
right so explain to us
in like the audience like what was your
mind
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome
to another episode of the genius brain
podcast i have edrick here with me on
the left
footsie buddies
it's like when somebody shakes your hand
and they do that little finger thing
[Applause]
well recently there has been
a very interesting turn with
cryptocurrency and i don't know [ __ ]
about it cryptos and nfts nfts we're
gonna go into that first
like so obviously you know if you've
been on
reddit or or anything else stocks
cryptocurrency and now there's something
called nfts that are involved so we
actually brought somebody here
that can explain to me because i'm a
[ __ ] idiot
so hey we're both here so why don't you
introduce yourself to everybody what you
do
and basically what you're known for
because uh well edric actually sent me
an article about you
right yeah i showed him i showed him the
the
remember i was telling you like uh i
came across that that people article
oh yeah you know when when it like he
was making those moves and then
yeah i showed dave that and dave was
like what the [ __ ]
i was like what the [ __ ] did you see did
you like send it
at the time when it like recently
happened or was this not too long after
okay yeah not too long after
but then but then i think like there was
kind of a stream of articles that were
coming out over the course of days
you know as as that information started
to make its rounds
and then people were kind of finding out
for the first time like
what nfts are and then even if they find
out they're like what the [ __ ]
i still don't get it i understand i want
you to introduce yourself yeah so um i'm
tim
uh i got into nfts quite recently
actually but
in the past i've been in crypto um
this was back in 2016 before kind of
like the bull run and um
working at a bank at the time i um
but not like not exactly like proud of
that i guess like because
why uh i don't know there's a lot of
shady [ __ ] though right
right right so um great old american
finances yeah
exactly and like but i love my job
though like my uh my boss and my
my teammate he was it was a good
experience like really kind of like
setting my foundation
yeah and like software development and
um
oh there's software development within
the bank yeah i see
okay yeah so so that goes because i
remember you're telling me you were both
a finance and computer science major
yeah right in college
i see yeah that sounds like a good like
kind of like blend it's a very specific
job yeah yeah so i was kind of like
making like
like uh the like visualizations for like
stock the stock trades and like being
able to create the database
i like when i hit the exchanges yeah
yeah you're coding all of that
yeah yeah um but like i wasn't doing
like the hard stuff i was doing mainly
like the
the the ui okay okay connecting it with
the whole database team and stuff so
yeah it was a great experience but i
kind of like
got into something that was the hedge of
it in a sense like
i got into cryptocurrencies which is
kind of like the antithesis of like
banks
right right um i mean if just because i
want to break it down for people who
don't know
just i'm talking about myself right now
what exactly is crypto right because
yeah you know i think we're
at a position now where especially now
online a lot of kids
say things that they don't know what the
[ __ ] it exactly is and i happen to be
one of those kids
so what is crypto exactly yeah so like i
think a lot of people
currently think of it as like a stock
but it's a lot deeper than that like the
fact that you can
kind of like own it yourself is that's
like kind of the
the paradigm shift because like um
nobody nobody owns like right the
network decentralized
yeah exactly the fact that it's
decentralized and yeah using a
traditional bank like they
kind of you know how they have servers
and stuff that they like you know keep
all the
records and everything and um like a
black swan event something can like come
and just like destroy
like i don't know the servers like banks
get hacked too you know yeah right but
like
cryptocurrency it can't really get
hacked because of the nature of it
right um so it's like it's basically
like
a ledger so like say one account
owns 10 bitcoin and then another account
owns 30
right and then um but it's basically
just
recorded and then all every single
computer that has
has this database then they all share it
right and so like if
if one computer says oh this account
that has 10
has zero but the rest of the rest of the
network says it has 10
that's it's it's just not true because
the rest of the the network agrees that
that's not true right and so um and then
back to the ownership point like
basically the the number
that you have publicly that's kind of
like your you have like an address like
a wallet
right and so um at your wallet address
your public address it'll say that has
10
but and then you have a private private
address a private key
which you use to access it right right
and if you lose that private key
it's like it's like a 50 character code
or something right like
yeah yeah so but there are ways to
really make it safe
so it's like um yeah you get
you kind of get like a like 24 words
that you can use to recover it but the
way that you really
keep it safe is you copy that you like
write it down right and then you give it
to like your family member
who you know like well well you know you
trust like with your life
yeah don't lose that thing i'm talking
from personal experience right
but that's that's more so when people
store it into like the wallets right
these digital wallets where that code
really comes into play if you're just
trading on an exchange or you just leave
the points on those exchange you don't
necessarily need that you just need your
login information yeah exactly so it's
like kind of like a
mix between a like a i guess a bank and
right
yourself they kind of like have custody
of your stuff yeah and so
or you could also even do cold wallet
right cold storage
you can put it onto like a usb drive and
then that way
you just oh that's so cool you transfer
it over
and you protect that [ __ ] with your
little yeah it's like how do you wanna
who
like do you wanna you know kind of like
have like
have control over your own funds or
would you rather give it to some
other entity which is pros and cons for
both right the ironic thing is is like
me hearing about people storing the cold
storage at their deposit boxes at the
you're banks the cryptocurrency at a
traditional you know institution but
um yeah um i i think that's kind of like
one thing to really distinguish though
is is like between exchanges and wallets
right of like how you hold and how you
own and how you trade cryptocurrencies
yeah for sure and in the us like the
coin base is pretty nice because
if they get hacked they actually ensure
i think it's like 250 000 right right
just like the fdic insurance yeah yeah
exactly so it's like um
so if you're if you have money within
that range maybe it's okay
but like i personally i like the idea of
kind of like taking ownership of
for yourself and i think it's a really
cool experience so maybe even like just
with like 100 bucks like it'd be cool to
just
kind of say oh like this is like the key
to 100 bucks
and then you know and then that that
feeling is is
different so did you so did you make
uh like you're living off of
cryptocurrency as of right now is that
what you do
yeah i guess yeah that's that is the
case i think because like
i i was working at a bank but i put like
i had like eight thousand dollars in
savings and i just threw it in
everything into it yeah and i also i
also took out a loan which is i do not
like wow
do not recommend wow you were that
gung-ho about the crypto movement yeah
to the point where you were willing to
take out a loan yeah what was
the amount of this loan it was like 12
12 000.
so like in my head i was like okay like
i'm i'm saving like 8 000
like in around a year so like if if i
take out this loan
and i currently like my job and like
what i'm learning and like what i'm
doing
if i take out a loan and i lose it all
then
another year of work is maybe not too
bad so that's kind of why
i took out that loan it wasn't it wasn't
a huge it wasn't like a hundred thousand
dollars
right right take out a mortgage i do
have a friend who took out a mortgage
and i was like bro
you're yeah you're crazy you're crazy
then
now it's like you're crazy rich
yeah and i've just been fortunate that
you know crypto really went up and i've
just kind of been sitting on it been
able to
quit my job and work on my own passions
and develop
their own things that i wanted wanted to
do so when people get into crypto right
like
in terms of like making a living do you
have to sell that crypto in order
to use like current currency right now
right yeah so like
basically i never really i tried trading
once
at work like like like i'm supposed to
be working but i was like
on the exchange like yeah yeah and like
it was just so much anxiety and i was
like up and down like just like
following the quick swings and i was
like all right like yeah and it was like
my my page was up and then like people
were walking by you know i'm just like
all right like i should not be good
i'm done i'm not doing this again well
the scary thing though
about trading in crypto too is that the
market's 24 hours
that's the [ __ ] man that's yeah that's
what gives you anxiety
right with the stock market you have
your your set hours and that's it
yeah weekends are closed crypto
exchanges
open 24 hours 365 seven days a week
and so like these movements can happen
while you're sleeping
and so i i know what that anxiety feels
like is when i first started trading
crypto too
yeah while i'm sleeping i'm dreaming
about this [ __ ] you know i'm like
dreaming about these swings happening
yeah like a big yeah bitcoin like
rolling and you're just like running
away from it
so i'd like to wake up like oh [ __ ] let
me check my phone like okay nothing
really is going on you know
so it's there's kind of like that
learning process of like
to try to disconnect yourself from those
hours that you need to
spend time resting or eating or whatever
but it's hard it's
it's very easy to get consumed and
sucked into that action
yeah for sure and that's why i i
recommend just kind of like
thinking and like a long-term outlook
you know right just like
just finding something that you believe
can actually impact the world in a sense
and then just try to get in at the
lowest price you can
or just like you know accumulate and
then just forget about it okay so let me
ask you this then
at the beginning what was the
sole reason like the primary reason that
you thought okay
this is definitely gonna be the future
so much so
that yes you know it's not a huge loan
but i'm still
willing to you know risk money that i
don't have pay interest on it
to to bet on this yeah yeah it's this
this is the the fun part i think like i
think it's
it's really important for the world um
and what really so basically i put all
my money into ethereum i never actually
really touched bitcoin unless i needed
to okay and it was really ethereum
because
bitcoin was cool in that like um you
it's
kind of like circumvents any it's like a
global
money you know it's like hard money it's
it it you can send a transaction to
someone
across the country within minutes and
you know make an exchange right
and that that was the cool thing about
bitcoin to me
but that's all bitcoin can really do is
just you can just send money to
each other right but ethereum it was
just mind-blowing to me because not only
can you just at
you know going back to the ledger go and
add an address that says okay you have
10 bitcoin
instead of that add an address you can
say you can put a piece of code
and so you can this code you can like
send
20 ether and then say
this account will hold it for 15 days
and then send it somewhere else
oh wow yeah so so like
i didn't know ethereum could do that so
yeah you can basically
put in kind of like a trigger order of
like okay after x amount of days then
send it to somewhere else yeah
all in one literally you can code like
anything
wow okay so it's like it's not only is
it just a like a
cryptocurrency but it's a distributed
computer in a sense because that's all a
computer is doing it just like
kind of like executes logic right and so
like not
not only just holding money but you can
send data like really easy just using
code you can say
with 2020 ether you can say hello
or like send a message and then it'll
sit there and then maybe like send the
message
somewhere else or or something you know
it's um
it's just like taking big it's like
bitcoin on crack
bitcoin is really like just a very nice
intro
into a way that you can see how like
money can go across
borders but like um the future
is this this global computer
yeah yeah so so this what does that
transition from like bitcoin to nft
comes in right so
first of all how about you explain what
the [ __ ] is nft
yeah yeah and so i've been waiting
like i've been in crypto and like when i
got into ethereum i was
i was really excited for kind of like
the implications that i had for the
world
um but at the time in 2017 when you know
a lot of other coins were popping up
it was really exciting and then it
crashed um a lot of the
a lot of this like stuff that was built
at that time using ethereum was just not
ready
um um so and then like also the entire
world thought it was a scam
right because there you know there were
like kind of like
shady things being being happening with
with bitcoin like
the hacks happening on the exchanges too
yeah there's just so
so much [ __ ] that that happened that was
kind of like oh it's like too
it's too scary right and so this podcast
is brought to you by skillshare
my friends you guys already know i've
been using skillshare for everything
that i need when it comes to
learning a skill that i want to either
improve on
or just learn in general right now i'm
taking a course called productivity for
creatives and by the way
this is just a specific course that i'm
taking they have a bunch of courses for
everything i know a lot of people are
into video right now or even writing
there's oh let me tell you something the
adobe premiere
tutorials on here have saved my ass
specifically when it comes to editing
skillshare my friends just to give you
guys a little bit more
specified city is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning
with so much more to explore real
projects to create and the support of
fellow creative skillshare
empowers you to accomplish real
growth now my genius brain listeners
explore your creativity at
skillshare.com
brain and get a free trial of premium
membership
at skillshare.com brain once again
that's
com skillshare.com brain and nfts
have it's been around for a while but um
i didn't quite realize it until recently
because of
art right right and that was the most
interesting thing that's what caught my
attention
yeah because i'm a huge fan of just art
you know any medium of art in general
yeah and if he stands for what
nft stands for non-fungible token so
an nft so think you know how bitcoin can
be divisible
yeah right um a non-fungible token
an nft is represents just a single
unit so you can't really you can't
divide it
so what it kind of works as is like a
single
representation of of an
asset that you can own right so it's
kind of like that
one of one or like one of five two or
five three or five marking
on that to make it like so that you know
that that is a legit
piece and it's from this creator or from
this collection or this artist or
whatever exactly
it's that digital signature it's just
exactly it's a digital
certificate like it's a it's like a
certificate
of authenticity that like you own and
you can transfer it to someone else you
know it's like
yeah and that makes oh i can kind of see
that so that's kind of dope because
with a lot of like these one of like for
example like these artworks right these
are prints
right and there's like a number it's
just 46 out of 50. well
a lot of people can go ahead and just
write this same [ __ ] with the same
handwriting and be like what are you
talking about i had the 46
yeah yeah what so i guess like with this
because it's digital
there's like a specific code for it then
yeah exactly
exactly so like imagine if every single
art piece
came with an nft that
said that it came from the the artist
you know so what an art what an artist
can do is they create the nft they mint
it
um and then they sell it or they can
give it away or whatever right and so
like
within the the ledger of
because every everything that happens is
kind of recorded in history so
so and it's permanent like because it
just can't get taken down because like
the whole network is is running it so
it's
it's you know it's trustworthy and so
the artist can create
maybe just one copy or five copies and
then
you'll see that their address that
they're the they're the rightful creator
you know because they've proven that
this this is me right right right and
then they can transfer it to someone
else
and then and then you you're trying to
ownership yeah transfer ownership
and then you can basically you basically
have proof
that like proof forever this is the od
this is
authentic authentic yeah how do you
create an nft token
like how does that work um there's
platforms where they kind of make it
easy so you can just like
upload something and then they'll create
one for you yeah oh okay i thought you
had to call it yourself i'm like
i was like [ __ ] that dude so like i
remember
um back in like 2017
uh when i was like looking at other
crypto projects right
one of them was v chain and like one of
v chains
goals possible like goals that they had
on the list
was to authenticate
luxury goods and they wanted to do that
for like let's say louis vuitton purses
like gucci items
and basically using blockchain
technology
putting it on like a hard piece of paper
or something with that code on there to
verify
this is authentic because you know
there's so much counterfeit goods for
that type of stuff
so at that time i was like oh [ __ ]
that's a
real like good uh use case scenario
where it would work for that type of
stuff and then so like when i learned
about nfts
it was it kind of connected in that
sense for me i was like
it's just that but digital you know
they're keeping it digital
whereas with the v chain idea it was
like taking digital and still
making it something physical where like
you can scan it to to verify
but then this is like all online and
then it started really blowing my mind
because i'm like
dude there can be a
real uh shift into just like digital art
all these art collectors that are out
there who collect these
like tangible art has always been about
tangible goods right
like i'm buying this collector's item
because
one it's rare and two i can hold it i
can display it i can
because that's what it is right like art
i mean there are people who appreciate
art for what it is and what artists do
but let's be real man like
within the art collecting world it's a
flex game you know what i mean
it like showcasing a piece that you have
at your home that costs five million
dollars that might be the only one that
exists
is the flexing right you're you're
flexing on it so like for me i feel like
with nfts
once people can kind of figure out like
how you can
flex with that that's when it becomes
like really mainstream
right because right now as much as it's
like traction as it's gotten i feel like
it's still early in the game very early
in the game and like
what it can become and what it might
eventually be
down the line and even in the near
future we have still yet to see that
yeah because because like i i don't know
you can chime in here but like when i
see
all of these uh nfts that are on these
uh marketplaces now i guess that's
what you would call it right nft
marketplaces yeah
i i see some of them bringing in artists
that are um known and credible
and then you just have random artists
yeah and then so it's like
well how do you really place value
on these pieces right like what's not to
say right now that this is just a bubble
that's forming
right everybody just caught up in the
hype right and and now it's like
this is the new [ __ ] this is what's cool
this is what's hype right now
and so anything and everything goes you
know and and like
value can be super inflated mm-hmm
like what's your take on that yeah so
in terms of the marketplace being kind
of like just flooded
um that is kind of currently an issue
right now because
the the way to kind of fix that is like
curation you know
there can be respected people who are
good at curating like right
good art is um and so yeah
the platforms are kind of like really
starting to starting to
develop still and so um
but the the reason i was just so excited
about nfts was because
before digital art was not really
respected
yes at all right it's like
um you know there there are digital
artists who
spend so much time and they make a
beautiful piece
and then they just upload it to
instagram right and it just shared
everywhere yeah
and so like the value that they get for
for doing that is
maybe some some followers right and if
they you know if they
really put put good effort into it and
start getting a following
then maybe they'll end up with like
client work you know or sell prints
right yeah or sell prints um but
it's changing now and like the
traditional art industry
like traditional artists they their
their hustle is kind of they
they're able to create a piece and then
they can they can go to a gallery and
people will sell it because they can
they can own it
but in the past you
like that you couldn't even fathom like
owning a
a freaking jpeg right right why would
you want to because like
you just find it anywhere yeah right
once it's up in the internet
it exists there forever yeah like people
people
usually say like oh i can just copy
paste it like so so
what's the big deal yeah what's the
value in it like what what
yeah but the value is that like when
when an artist creates an nft they can
say that i've only made one authentic
copy that i would like to sell
right or five or something and so
when you buy that nft yeah like anybody
can copy and paste it
that's actually a good thing because
that kind of like creates more
visibility yeah with a piece yeah
but anyone who copies and pastes it they
don't own the nft so they don't they
can't
resell they can't sell a jpeg right they
can sell the nft right
so because there's a marketplace
they can actually buy and and resell
what is this token
yeah so what it's doing is like it's
giving like definitive value to the
original artwork
exactly exactly you can you can have a
bunch of mona lisa replicas
you know and it can look real and it can
seem like the real thing but there's
only
one authentic one and it's in a museum
right
they're able to verify that just like
that it's like
yeah you can have millions of of it be
of like an image be reproduced an art
piece be reproduced
there's only gonna be one authentic
piece i wonder if like
companies like dreamworks and disney are
going to start creating nfts
for like the original i think i would i
wouldn't be surprised i think it's
like they haven't already done that
they're probably talking about it yeah
yeah right now
i think it's inevitable because there's
dollars and cents in it yeah because
before even now like
like in in sacramento there's like this
curator of old disney art right
and this is like the original artwork
that you know whoever created who the
[ __ ] i don't know who created mickey
mouse but that [ __ ]
that's funny that is legend the [ __ ]
that created mickey mouse right like he
has like these little scribble scrabbles
or some [ __ ] right
and they're selling that [ __ ] for ten
thousand twelve thousand fifteen
thousand twenty thousand a piece
so essentially two it's like well now
i'm thinking well why can't they do that
for moana
it's like this was the first digital
completion of it here's the end
exactly exactly and it's happening like
there are artists in the space who have
done like
actual work for you know their their
comic artists for marvel
and that's that's you know how they kind
of
were part of part of marvel and they're
come as the
as an artist they're actually creating
new artworks that are like superhero
themes
basically superheroes and they they can
they can sell their work
and people want it because they're the
they're the artist
for it you know yeah and so even though
what's most exciting for me is not for
these big companies to kind of come in
and
yeah and sell their sell their ip in
this way because like they already have
money
you know to me and
it's like artists are the ones who've
been shafted for sure yeah
throughout history throughout history
yeah and
um you know people
a lot of a lot of digital artists mainly
do client work and they kind of
make things for someone else like maybe
microsoft or snapchat or whatever
and they don't they don't own any rights
you know they basically get paid
like an average wage or you know
the the the cost of the the contract and
then
that's it and then they they basically
sell their work to them
right and then they use it however they
like right but never has there been a
time when artists can
make what they love like without any
kind of like other
influence just like something that they
really love
something that would be in their
personal personal projects folder
not their client client folder and sell
it
yeah no it's it's it's beautiful for
sure it is it is
and i think a good like connector to to
that idea
is look at how graphic artists
like uh graphic designers are treated in
like the corporate world
right they're always getting low ball
always
you know trying to be like the people
who are trying to contract them or hire
them is like oh you know it'll give you
exposure
trying not to pay for it because like
you just said
creators artists have always been
shafted they always get the [ __ ] end of
the stick because
a lot of the people i actually i don't
want to say a lot of the people
there's a good chunk of people who don't
understand that creative process
don't have a creative inclination who
can't understand like the work that goes
into that you know what i mean it's not
like accounting where it's like
math and numbers because it exists in
the abstract it's not concrete
and then so like they don't understand
it and as a result
of being ignorant of it they don't
respect it by nature
and so
guys it seems so many times man like so
many instances were like
yeah the businessmen are always trying
to
basically cheap out on the artist or
take advantage of it
yeah because their work is like not work
you know because i'm also thinking now
like how cool would it be for like an
artist to
like for example like you have like a
hundreds thing right so let's say there
was a
specific graphic designer that created
that bomb right it's like well
yeah you could use it to print all this
other stuff but i had the nft for the
actual first digital artwork before it
was there yeah so it's like cool like i
got paid for this work
it's great we have a working
relationship but i
still have the ownership of this put it
on your sweaters whatever
right so he gets to still keep the value
of his artwork here which is really dope
yeah yeah it is it's really cool and
like actually what's even
what's what's really dope is that within
these nfts you can actually code
like royalties oh really yeah so like
when another
when someone like when it's reached when
it switches hands then you get
within the contract it can say that
twenty percent goes to the original
arctic that's sick yeah wow so
like pretty cool can now get like
perpetual income
right at work in the future out of their
hands dude that's [ __ ] beautiful
yeah it is it's it's crazy it's like
it's how the world should be
right you know that's [ __ ] insane
what this reminds me of
is like kind of technology
uh cultivating like um
artists to be like recording music
artists to be
more independent like cultivating that
culture that independent culture because
once it got to the point where like yeah
you know you can buy
a little setup for a few hundred bucks
and record at home now
you could mix this [ __ ] you could
produce this [ __ ] you could write this
[ __ ]
all on your own you don't need to go and
pay for studio time or go to
look for major labels to sign a deal and
that
gave artists so much more power to like
express take ownership of their art and
to put it out like also
not having technology just cater to like
the recording process but also
the distribution process right you could
upload it onto soundcloud you could
upload it onto spotify onto youtube you
could put it all out there
and basically have full ownership
ownership of it get all the revenue from
it
and not have to basically cave into what
the labels might want you to do
or even worse getting signed to a shitty
deal and then doing what the labels want
you to do
you know some some artists have you know
sold their soul away yeah yeah sucks
right and this is what it reminds me of
is like that type of freedom
you know but then on like obviously a
much bigger scale because it doesn't
just pertain to
music artists like it music hasn't even
really touched this yet
right i have oh yeah people are already
starting to go into that now
yeah yeah actually um yeah how fast it's
like let's say like bruno mars comes out
he goes
well i made this specific track but
there's only 50 copies of this
yeah you know and only 50 people can
have it yeah and they're like
people who really are true fans of bruno
mars you know
they want to collect it because they
they love bruno mars right
and there are other there are more fans
than 50 that might want it as well so
by you know by buying that one of the
copies you could
probably resale to someone yeah and also
it upholds value
and i could even see people doing that
and even holding like musical art
galleries
yeah you know it's like well you there's
only 50 copies of this
so i'm going to rent out this copy over
here and we're going to have this event
and then you get to hear all these
hidden tracks that nobody else can hear
because there's only 50 copies
yeah so that person would have to pay
something to rent out that music that'd
be [ __ ] insane yeah
yeah um actually speaking of bobby
hundreds he
he actually minted the the bomb emoji
on one of the platforms and i i bought
that
this is bobby i love i love
the hundreds and yeah it's like so i i
got that piece
so it's just literally an emoji yeah and
like i
bought an emoji
but like to me it has value because it's
just
iconic of the brand yeah you know yeah
and
i could probably sell it to someone
right who who thinks this is cool
okay so now let's let's speaking of that
of buying pieces
let's let's get to the big thing right
the article i mean this is public
information
you bought people's piece for 777
thousand dollars
right yeah now that [ __ ] in my pants
that is literally putting money put
putting your mouth or
your money where your mouth is
yeah to the average person that's a lot
of fun right so
explain to us in like the audience like
what was your mindset behind that of
like
this is worth it for me to to pony up
this amount of money
yeah in order to
i don't know like i don't want to say
make a point but like to to really drive
this movement
yeah right like what was your mindset
behind that yeah like um
so beeple he is he's a legend um
as a background he is his name is mike
winkelmann and he's known for
aka bill gates
he's known for creating a piece of art
every single day for 13 years without
fail
it's crazy dude have the the silent to
do that yeah so if you go to his
respectable yeah if you go to his
instagram like
if you want to like you know check every
single day he has not failed
like he he has committed himself to the
to his craft
and dedicated himself to learning well i
feel like [ __ ] now
but yeah like but to artists to a lot of
like artists that was
it's just he's just such an inspiration
you know and
um people that actually know about him
don't know that he
has done a lot of work outside of that
he does like
crazy dope animations and
him and um fig um they actually had done
the visuals for the super bowl right
yeah like so just quick background figgy
is the friend
that i told you about who they're
possible
okay yeah possible productions yeah
possible productions they basically do
he combines basically art and technology
right and so
all of those visuals that you see at
like these concerts at these events
let's say like the grammys you know yeah
super bowl right
and then so people was basically doing
contract work with them with with
possible
for these visuals yeah so he's legit
you know and um but even as someone
who's been doing like
legit work like basically like if you've
been to a concert before
um or you know like edm festivals you
have seen his stuff
right but i didn't know about him right
i didn't know that was him
you know like um and artists aren't
really getting the
kind of like the recognition that they
deserve both
both recognition and the monetary
compensation
making a good livelihood from it yeah
and like what i realized was that
nfts was the way to liberate
artists and creativity you know because
now
artists can make a living for themselves
and do doing what they love
it's just never like like this before
you know it's never been like this and
and so he had reached out and showed me
what he was working on i was like oh
snap yeah like
this is sick and he showed me it was
like this this box
he created this box with this acrylic
um frame which is by infinity objects
but he kind of he
he kind of customized it and it was his
digital art piece
and kind of like animated in this box
wow and
like he you know also attached
a qr code to it so basically you can
when you go to it it will
go to the blockchain and then you can
verify it's authentic what i was talking
about earlier about like verifying
luxury goods kind of the same idea right
exactly yeah and so like this guy
he actually had done like a sale before
but like the fact that he made so much
money just blew his mind he's like oh
[ __ ] like
i know yeah like he made what four mil
over like a weekend or something
yeah yeah so actually so he did like a
drop before it beforehand yeah so
he sold two pieces for like 66k uh-huh
um
and then sold like a hundred um
pieces for a dollar each and
those pieces at the when i when i saw it
yeah they were reselling for like
two thousand three thousand holy [ __ ]
wow and
and he sold it for a dollar did he have
and he put his little
nft thing he had he verified it yeah
each one is an nft basically
holy [ __ ] so every time it resold he got
a
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] it's been it's been
switching hands like crazy right but
but it's like more and more because it's
reselling for two thousand dollars and
now you're getting twenty percent of two
thousand dollars
and then twenty percent of four thousand
dollars and ten thousand dollars exactly
so as long as the value's there
it's like that residual keeps coming
that's exactly crazy
yeah yeah and so like when i saw it and
at the same time that he had reached out
it was three thousand dollars
and i just like immediately bought one i
was like this guy is legit
yeah yeah and like at the time that that
was that that was a lot of money
and he should have a lot of money at any
time
yeah yeah so when was this when was this
that happened in november in november
okay 2020. and just uh just to just
put out there these are the same pieces
yeah i think the last sale was like two
hundred thousand dollars
oh for a one dollar piece damn people
are buying it for 200
200. my mind is [ __ ] blowing
like what is going on and he like every
time that switches hands he's making
like i think ten percent or something
like
that
okay parents told me that being an
artist would make me poor
i think i think every asian i think that
was true back then
yeah you know yeah
i was so good at doodling i'm so upset
right now dude
you know what i love about this too
[ __ ] specifically 2d art
right anime artist they make [ __ ] they
make
nothing exactly like it's so
disappointing right because
i love 2d animation yeah like i i
appreciate where 3d animation is going
it's super beautiful but there's like an
archery to 2d animation that is
dying because they can't make money yeah
and it kills me to watch it i watch the
whole
dock watching these [ __ ] anime
artists
right creating some of the art that i
really really love
and they're barely getting by and
they're working [ __ ] like 24 hours
every day sleeping maybe a second a day
and they look insane they look
disgusting you know
especially within like japanese work
culture right yeah it's so intense
do you have any idea how many white
people would buy those [ __ ] monkeys
they would be reselling to be fair now
any ethnic group like because manga is
like
i mean anime has gone mainstream people
who spend money on it
this shit's gonna change though yeah
it's gonna change yeah
and you know the reason that i so going
into that auction
um i did not intend on winning that like
i i wanted to support this guy because i
thought like
he could really stand for something like
because drive the price of free duck
yeah like basically going back to the
box what he did was really
blend the entire spectrum of the nft and
a physical collectible
because nfts aren't really they had they
had been around and same thing with kind
of like
parrying a physical and an nft it's it's
been around
but the way that he did it at his
caliber was just like
on another level you know and no one's
really
done something like this before yeah and
you bought that [ __ ] for how much
force a thousand dollars man
yeah so um i didn't intend on it though
um but your heart said yes
exactly man exactly and like um
i i when i put the bid in like the bid
before was
30 or something and i had goddamn
yeah so you jumped the 330 000 bid
to 777 000. i don't really yeah so
like i even texted him i was like hey
man like this is my this is my cap
like yeah i'm out like he's like you
know dude like thank you so much like i
appreciate you
and yeah because this is crazy to him
too it's crazy to everybody
bro everybody and like i was sitting
there watching the timer
like dang i get i guess that's it and i
the thing is i wanted to buy a different
piece so there were like 20 different
auctions okay
they were going for like a hundred grand
each just like absolutely crazy yeah
like it was literally breaking records
yeah um
and i wanted one of the pieces and i
couldn't put my bid in
for some reason i when you put sense and
like when you add cents to it
sometimes it just doesn't go through i
was trying to put 69 cents
and then it just wouldn't go through and
i'm like oh damn and i couldn't put my
bid in and i'm like oh man
yeah and and i reached out i was like
hey man i think the website shafted me
but yo good luck man this is crazy
yeah you know so it wasn't tilt bit in a
second i didn't have that
like that i didn't have that much money
in my account actually and then he was
like oh
and i didn't tell him this but i just
told him that the website shouted me but
he was like
no worries man like let me like i could
get you on the white list
yeah what's the white list yeah and then
like he connected me to the founder and
he's like
yup you're whitelisted for 1.5 million
i'm like
holy [ __ ] thank you
i'm probably not going to use it yeah
like that's really cool yeah
um what does whitelist mean basically
you could put in a bid without the money
in your account yeah and i was like
it's like a marker yeah and like he
didn't even like
screen me either like i i haven't really
put myself out there publicly he just
like did it for me i was like right
all right cool i mean if the if the the
prime
you know guy the star of the show is
vouching for you
right the guy probably thinks yeah he's
you know he's probably good for it uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah true um so
it was at like 333 and like the timer
was running down i didn't even like see
the timer
i was just like looking at the buy page
with the timer
and the timer wasn't there yeah no and i
put the bid and i was just like
do i do this and i'm looking at the box
with
seven seven seven zero zero zero do i
click yes it is like it was like way
above my threshold yeah and i was just
like what
and i really had no idea what was going
on in my head
i just i just decided to click it uh-huh
and apparently it was the very last
second and then it reset the timer to
five minutes and then like
everybody was like [ __ ] this yeah and
i was just like what what did i just do
that'd be so funny if you just put in
like
335 and everybody's like this is too
much
it was basically between me and this
other guy so nobody else was really
bidding but
like um the thing is also people were
kind of like expecting it to
be over one mil so i thought like that
would have been
yeah that somebody else had like yeah i
thought i thought i would have been
outbid anyways
and so i was like [ __ ] it yeah and then
um and then i won and then i texted him
like what the [ __ ] just happened
a very rich man that's so funny that
even
you yourself are thinking what the [ __ ]
just happened yeah and he was like what
the [ __ ]
and like the only thing we could both
think was like what the [ __ ] yeah and
like
um it took a little bit of time for me
to realize what i did yeah because like
i really did want to validate the space
because
like i saw how art again
is the medium to communicate something
like just be the new renaissance and
this
like this is even more important than
any other like
not any other but like you know it's
super
super important in our lifetime anyway
yeah yeah because it's
liberating people across the globe right
like artists and like kenya can just
make a dough piece right
sell it and make like money that this is
literally happening there are artists
across the globe
who are selling a single piece that's
like
almost a year's worth of like
of money that they can make working a
job in their country what was the piece
that you bought
um it was it was
so there were like 20 different auctions
yeah but this it was like the final
piece
and that was the 21st auction that had
all 20 within the one
that was kind of like the final auction
is that the box that you brought
yeah i did i did bring it uh should i
should i pull it out yeah
yeah let's check it out why am i palm
sweaty
just uh hearing the kind of money it's
like dave's getting nervous from
oh my god i'm sweating right now dude
yeah so i brought this because i thought
it would be nice to kind of like show
your audience
yeah what it is let's see so he
basically created this box
and i was just he created this box and i
was like this is
he showed it to me i was like damn it's
really dope yeah
um what and the [ __ ]
yeah he like packaged it and you guys
should just read it oh my god okay
be careful with it be careful yeah so it
says on the bus the most
important thing about art is to work
nothing else matters except sitting down
every day and trying by stephen
i love this [ __ ] this [ __ ] real
ass [ __ ]
bro this is and then so this
showcases the art pieces now how do you
turn it on
yeah just actually yeah why don't you
just you just pull it out
just pull it out yeah yeah yeah you do
all right all right my palms are
starting to sweat
so just use this thing to pull it out
right here um yeah there should be a
little does it say there's a hair sample
in there yeah
and i i think it says on there that it's
like it's not pubes
this isn't this dude's hair like his
actual
that is as authentic as it gets there
that's yes
another personal touch to it but okay so
this
is the oh dude
that's sick so it's like touch censored
yeah it just comes as soon as you lift
it out it turns on so you saw the screen
was off right
as soon as i picked it up it just
clicked all the other yeah
it flipped on so
wow yeah so when i saw this i was like
this is dope
because you can have you can actually
collect a digital
that's the digital right item yeah
i really did it before i really like
what he did here that is [ __ ] genius
dude because it's
like it's it's kind of easing your way
into the marriage of both worlds exactly
like
not everyone's going to understand or
even care that like oh you can buy like
a digital file
yeah but then you got the qrc code right
here to verify it
you got the piece dude that's sick man
that's sick wait so so there's value
both in the
the digital part and the physical part
yeah so the the kind of like
analogy that it makes is that they're
supposed to be a pair you know like when
you
when you sell the the nft you basically
want to
make sure this comes with it and the
person that buys it is probably gonna
want both you know and so the analogy he
makes is it's kind of like cutting
a baseball card in half like you might
have both pieces but like
there's it just kind of like destroys
the value it's like a [ __ ] anime
where it's like
there's like something that destroys the
world but you need both pieces
if not it's worthless dude my mind is
[ __ ] blown this was like some [ __ ]
that i would
i forgot i watched like movies where you
see like digital artwork hanging on the
wall
and you know it kind of seems ridiculous
where they're like
it'll be like some kind of matrix [ __ ]
right where it's like in the future and
they go oh this is my art piece and you
see this hologram or something right
yeah
that's what this [ __ ] is it is and like
before it would you would be like if it
was in real life before it would be like
what the [ __ ] is the point because like
it's just like it's just a file that's
kind of playing there
but now that you can like literally
display like a digital piece and
now you can say i own this it's it's
different
before you can just say oh i'm this i
own this jpeg that i've framed here on
my tv
you can actually own a digital piece
absolutely [ __ ] it's it's really
like just like everyone
should do that yeah no that's that's
what he's trying to
go for and the the people who actually
manufactured the
the the frame they're called infinity
objects okay but they're like
backordered as hell because he came out
worse this is
that is like this coolest things i've
ever seen in my [ __ ] life dude yeah
it's so cool
it's like there's no other word besides
that's [ __ ] cool yeah
you know what i mean yeah yeah and the
fact that it's you know as soon as you
you pick it up boom it just
it just like like my mind is blown right
now
it's like yeah it blew my mind yeah i
was like
but but here's here's the great thing
here's the great thing about
introducing like the tangible good side
to it
is that when you have like let's say a
mj rookie card right
that [ __ ] is in like a [ __ ] thick-ass
acrylic case
yeah yeah you're not gonna touch it
you're not gonna move it this
it doesn't really [ __ ] matter it
doesn't matter because it's the digital
file this is just
no that's perfect completely true like
honestly if i
lose this yeah like someone steals it or
whatever like it's not going to have
value he can just
probably make another one but i own the
actual
asset that is tradable right like
you can't really you i guess you could
sell this to someone but like what
matters is the nft
right right because that's what has like
the signature right that's
another one of that with because you
actually haven't so yeah he can make
another one of these so
it's actually like oh the physical has
become less important
although it's dope it's a great way to
showcase yeah exactly
it's not like you have to be so you know
careful and like
yeah that is so [ __ ] cool yeah it's
crazy right it's
especially for somebody like me like if
when i had things of value i freaked the
[ __ ] out
so now if i was like hey do whatever the
[ __ ] you want [ __ ]
yeah i'll [ __ ] kill you with that
thing
okay
yeah that is what it is i mean it's kind
of interesting that you would have the
foresight for something like this right
because i think if somebody you know a
simple mind is me when somebody tells me
about this i can't wrap my head around
it right
because i've been only been thinking in
like in the traditional sense like i'm
not thinking like steps ahead
you know but this is i mean it's just
revolutionary it's revolutionary yeah
it's revolutionary it's a game changer
and like i've been waiting for something
like this for
since ever since i got into crypto and i
was like
and then when i saw this i was like it
just clicked to me because like
art is the way that people can start
understanding about ownership
for yourself absolutely and absolutely
and it's a unique language and like
self-sovereignty you know
it's art and that's uh so i'm just like
balls deep in it you know that's why i
put that bit in because like
i i was just like dude this is the
future like yeah like this is the guy
and you know ever since like the whole
world is
it's the world is shook right now like
this is so insane because now i'm just
like hey
like what if what if one of these were
art this is like a large art piece on
the wall
yeah right and yeah you see like the
yeah the code and everything
exactly and you can actually say i own
this yeah because these things
are all digital right but it's
representing
the replicas they're printed out yeah
yeah so why would he
what's the whole point of having this
physical piece like well you could just
have the digital and you just play it up
and then you have the actual cert you
know the nft for it yeah
that's way better yeah no you should go
and ask the the artist like
you should get into this and like see it
yeah i'm sure yeah tommy yeah
especially a guy like tommy because his
medium is
digital yeah he does everything
digitally i want
i want my nft i bought this 46 out of
50.
you [ __ ] i want the opt-in
authentication i want the authentication
immediately yeah
um but you know as crazy as it might
sound
in terms of like what you actually bid
and paid for it
probably it's a great [ __ ] investment
though yeah so like
when i bought this like i didn't share
it with anyone yeah i i just like bought
it and i just stayed quiet yeah because
like
honestly like at the time if there were
people that i knew that that
you know my acquaintances and friends
like if they had known or like found out
that i
dropped 700 grand on a jpeg
yeah they'd be like this guy's an idiot
yeah he's like
like [ __ ] that's your mindfulness
he's just throwing money away yeah you
know and like that's
at the like that's i feel like how
people would perceive it
you know um without fully grasping the
gravity right you just didn't want the
attention
yeah i didn't want to i didn't want that
to happen so i just kind of like stayed
quiet
and um and like you know even
after buying this i even with the whole
community like on twitter
everything's happening on twitter right
community right it's it's awesome like
yeah it's such a vibrant like inspiring
like everyone's so motivated right now
yeah
um like i just kind of like kind of kept
to myself but like
after i started connecting slowly and
then people actually reached out
and had told me like that was a great
buy yeah
i was like oh [ __ ] and they're like yeah
i feel better
um do you think this is already like
appreciated in value so absolutely uh
yeah yeah it has like i've got an offer
that's that's been like quite high
that i rejected and you're like [ __ ] you
i rejected it because to me it just has
such sentimental value
i mean this is your first like major
major purchase yeah yeah something
you're i mean yeah by the way i don't i
don't spend my money recklessly yeah
like
like um something different this is this
is a
passion move let's let's be clear about
that it's not like you're just some
[ __ ] trust fund baby
you know who just got all this
disposable income and being like yeah
i mean 770 thousand here you know 800
000 there i just [ __ ] throw it away
yeah this was like something you
believed in that
like you said you were looking for it to
happen and it finally did
in in in this way yeah and this guy he's
just such he's a great guy like
mike mike winkleman people he's just he
all of his work he actually puts out a
lot of it he just puts out for free
just to help others and just learn and
just use you know
i'm so shocked that he makes an art
piece a day and i saw some of his stuff
like in that article
yeah no every single piece is was done
in like two hours or less or
wow around that time amount it's crazy
dude to not get
turned out just kind of like have your
creative juices flowing
every single day for 13 years just
always on
that's an incredible yeah
yeah so a lot of people respect him he's
just he's a legend
and like how obscure his art is when he
just looks kind of like you're
like i said a bill gates you know like
that's what a lot of articles are saying
right he looks like you're bill gates
type of guy
but then the i don't even see that but
but yeah apparently people are saying
that
yeah this is like so cool
like even for like specifically for
digital photography now
yes and there's there's a platform
called fpmera.com
um but they're focused on lens-based
nfts
yeah and that's amazing yeah you know
because that's that's like the sad part
right you'll see like people's photos
like say for somebody goes all the way
to the appalachians they take this photo
right
and it just gets shared [ __ ]
everywhere and then you don't know who
the [ __ ] the person
that throws his [ __ ] [ __ ] off it
balls off or some [ __ ]
depending on who it is up on a [ __ ]
mountain side yeah and you just see this
picture and people just scroll right
through it just like hold on a second
like
that's really dope yeah yeah yeah
like i think it's going to help people
kind of like take more time looking at a
digital piece too
because you know people see things on
instagram that's like
really dope but probably they're just
like look at it for a sec like all right
next yeah but like
artists spent a lot of time like really
making a
like a piece like maybe there's like
many many underlying messages behind
that
right right and if people are like
buying this stuff for like
a considerable amount because they
actually have taken the time to look at
it
other people are gonna see the same and
i think and you know if they're
i i see the future of like art galleries
starting to have like digital frames
and then that like these galleries also
bought start buying pieces
and they display it and
honestly like i i love seeing like these
digital pieces and i think when i go to
a gallery seeing like
really dope digital pieces would be
really like compelling for me to go and
like
and check out because i think it's
really cool yeah but yeah but like on
instagram
people me myself included like a lot of
times i'm just looking
scroll through yeah i mean and that and
that's the kind of the sad thing about
like digital art is that it just gets
mixed in with all the media that's out
there all the digital media you know
and you there's so much [ __ ] that's like
fighting for your attention that yeah
when you just look at a digital piece
you might not have the same frame of
mind of
viewing that piece like you would let's
say if you walk into a gallery
like there you're you're there to really
appreciate the art
whether it's like a solo artist showcase
or like multiple artists
you're there to like look consume really
look at the pieces
and and think about things versus oh
that's a dope piece next next next right
yeah
like a dope piece mixed in with like you
know oh we're partying oh
we're at the beach oh we're eating at
this nice restaurant right
yeah and then so it just becomes one of
those things you know what i mean but
then like to
bring value into it to bring like
authenticity into it uh scarcity into it
because that's a big thing right
scarcity as well right yeah yeah that
that creates value
you know then now it's like oh
you got to shift your mind a little bit
now maybe you want to pay attention here
you know maybe what you're looking at is
is by
an up-and-coming artist or already a
dope artist that
you want to pay attention to and and
like follow um
because yeah like i said before
since money's involved in this it's
gonna attract you know people who aren't
light
art aficionados too right people who are
just looking to invest or make a quick
buck flipping it and then you're going
to bring corporate world's going to come
into here because
you know they're going to see an
opportunity that they're not going to be
able to pass up on
and so there is going to be dilution
that happens for sure
but even still just the fact that now
the technology and the platforms exist
for artists
to be able to get fair compensation for
their work
fair value for their work um it's
incredible man it is really
it really is it's it's mind-blowing and
it's beautiful like i just i love it
like i
just i i love the idea and like i
actually like started a charity
to to help um give grants to oh
wow artists that don't have any
recognition that's sick
that's sick yeah that's so that's what
i've been busy with lately and like
okay so that's how you're trying to like
progress that movement is through your
charity now
yeah so after this you know like the
whole world is talking about it right
now at least the people like behind the
scenes that are
like all like all musicians all djs they
all know about it yeah like they're all
scrambling like trying to figure out
like
how do we how to be part of this right
like we can't we can't miss out on
and like i'm sure corporations are going
to come in and ever and whatnot but
and but the thing is like people who
have already made money like that's not
why that's not what i bought this piece
for you know
like this is empowering creativity and
for for the independent artists you know
and so
it's like kind of like a double-edged
sword you know like as as this
progresses like there's going to be
like the influx of every kind of facet
of of
of interest um so i just wanted to
really
make sure that it's this progression is
still like
you know healthy and and just like
helping people out so what's the name of
your uh
your foundation um it's called sevens
foundation
sevens and it's set up like people find
it online
yeah it's uh i got i got a sick domain
name it's grants.art
really yeah it's like i'm like
just the domain value of that well you
know
i'm sure you're gonna have people
offering you money for that yeah but
um yeah so that's it's uh
it's something that's something i'm
working on right now and we actually had
applica
we opened applications around less than
two weeks ago and
we've already had like six over six
hundred wow and it's it's
yeah it's been super exciting out there
for for people on twitter just on
twitter and
um so we have like a committee of uh of
people who have kind of been like
prominent in the space already digital
artists and they're kind of like also
promoting
it and it's kind of like a collective
effort so just make sure this is like a
healthy like
you know authentic thing that's yeah
it's kind of cool too because
when you when i see like let's say a new
movement in digital art where people get
more recognition
it's it's also cool because people who
still do physical art
there's going to be people who are who
love that and that's going to appreciate
the value of physical art as well
right it's like oh i don't do [ __ ]
digital art i do physical art still
and those [ __ ] people are going to be
snobs and it's going to put their value
up as well too
so it kind of works for all artists on
all ends yeah it does
and because like the physical like
physical art
can really make use of an nft like they
can
create an nft for a physical piece that
they did yeah and just attach a qr code
on the back
right and then now you have like an
authentication marker
but it's just the the physical piece is
the same but you can now like
have like a global marketplace at your
access right awesome
you know so that authentic the
authentication part is so much easier
than
i've been watching what's that show the
[ __ ] pawn star [ __ ] right and they
have to authenticate this japanese
samurai sword
they gotta get this [ __ ] white dude
and he's basically guesstimating you
know he's making guesses he goes oh this
was from
this this japanese woman's [ __ ] here
and it bound up the hilt
you know how do you know these things
you know and then he has to guesstimate
how much it's worth but instead if you
have a qr code it's like
this is authentic there's no other way
yeah you know no second guessing it it's
just a scan
and boom there it is verified yeah it's
so there's a lot of plus sides for for
physical
for traditional artists it's it's you
know uh kind of
like the blue check mark right next to
your name
it really is like how much value is that
worth oh man i'm gonna start right i'm
gonna start cracking up though when you
have like influencers who are like
shitty at art
they're gonna like i got i have not had
the case logan paul bro he made his own
nft he
[ __ ] made two million wait what how
does he make it and what does he have
i don't know what he did what what what
the piece was are you familiar with that
yeah i actually bought one but i didn't
actually
think like more of it i was just like
okay like this guy
is popular might as well yeah but you
know like he was
obviously cashing in on the crazy yeah
yeah yeah
and so he he made what i think two
million over the weekend right something
like that yeah yeah
what was the nft for what was it it was
just justin nessy
i don't know i don't recall the details
like i was i literally was just like all
right like maybe
it's a maybe it's a piece of history
like whatever yeah
oh yeah i don't i'm not sure what the
piece was
but yeah this guy he he
cashed in on that quick as soon as like
it started percolating
and then i was like all right logan paul
to create his own
yeah i'm gonna
[Music]
now here's the question is like
obviously
this thing this space is going to grow
and you know more and more people are
gonna find out about
it learn about it participate in it um
but with the kind of the hype that's
around it now do you think
it's actually harmful to the movement in
terms of like creating
too much hype and in like a bubble in a
sense of like
all of these people coming in thinking
oh [ __ ] this is where the money's at
you know yeah let me [ __ ] buy up all
of these things that
are pretty much valueless but it's
perceived as value because of the hype
yeah you know once that bubble pops
probably ninety percent of this shit's
gonna be worthless yeah right i can say
that
yeah but that's art in general though
there is no general marker for what the
value of art is
it's created by people yeah but what i'm
saying what i'm saying is like it's
driven by hype right now
you know like it's really driven by like
dollars
yeah and popularity yeah i do think a
lot of things that are being sold are
overvalued because like a lot of
a lot of the so there's a platform
called nifty gateway that has kind of
been like
like the pop and popular one um that's
actually the the site that people
dropped his things on and like there are
people who
are coming in with shitty art it's like
objectively shitty
this is [ __ ] yeah and like um
it's you could tell that they didn't
really put
the thought into the art you know and
just because of their clout like it's
being bought up like crazy
well that's what i'm saying like this is
going to be with these influencers yeah
they're going to scribble some [ __ ] yeah
with their clown
yeah so definitely like i definitely
would caution people like
just to not buy things because honestly
like i really
i don't know never mind um
all right um i lost my thought now
yeah there's going to be people that are
that are going to be coming in and like
you know making a cash grab it's like a
cash crap you know and like
um when you when you buy these pieces it
you kind of want to
see it as like a long-term thing you
know yeah like that's
there's a lot of people also like
flipping and
i i used to be like ah like you're
flipping like
but i can't really knock it because it
creates a market yeah it's an economy
right yeah
yeah it creates an account and there's
people who are flipping who
have never had the opportunity to make
money like this before and you know
they're
it's changing people's lives so it's
just like damn you can't you can't knock
their hustle yeah exactly yeah
yeah i think the cool thing is because i
mean i'm only based literally bases off
this dock that i saw in how art is
curated
like physical art and it's literally
just a bunch of rich people sitting in
rooms saying this is worth a million
yeah you know and that's just how it
works
yeah you know but i think the difference
is here it's like even if it's like some
[ __ ] social media [ __ ]
right he has garnered an x amount of
followers and
he has like this kind of like the social
currency that can actually turn
the currency so that to me is more
viable than this [ __ ]
millionaire buying this [ __ ] piece
from this french dude saying i bought it
for a million and then they're like oh
so they must be worth a million
there's actual some tangible value that
you could see to it
even if it is like that like logan paul
right well
he actually has a following so it makes
sense for him to create something given
nft and give it value because
he has a value in the society yeah as
long as he has a brand and a platform
it'll have value yeah yeah so i see that
being more viable
than there's these other art pieces like
when i because i was curious about what
how the [ __ ]
why is this because i went to the the
broad
right which i was calling the broad and
people [ __ ]
why the [ __ ] did you spell it broad then
[ __ ] so i know that right
i go to the broad yeah [ __ ]
excuse me all right and i go there and i
see
this piece of paper on the wall and it
has
it's in charcoal and it's six dicks
that are drawn that thing was worth two
million dollars
and i'm like how how the [ __ ] is that
worth two million dollars and i look at
this other wall
and it's just somebody it looks like
what kids draw on a desk
on this huge piece and it was worth like
10 mil and i'm like i
i don't how right and i can't wrap my
head around it i'm looking into it
and i'm researching what it is it's like
some [ __ ] explanation for why it's
worth this amount of money
like who the [ __ ] was this and you just
look it up it's some [ __ ] that bought it
for this amount of money and
that's how he gave it the value and that
was it you know and so
when i see that it's like this is
ridiculous i do chocolate dicks when i
was a kid all the time
like super bad drunk yeah
i got in trouble for you so when i hear
this like even like logan paul like he
has some type of social currency in this
world so when he creates something
there's
some type of tangible tangible backing
for it yeah it makes more sense to me
yeah for sure for sure yeah and you know
the thing about art
and this is true throughout like history
and the entire existence of mankind has
always been
subjective right you can't like you know
i know earlier you just said it's
objectively [ __ ] right but somebody
might look at that
and and think wow this is really amazing
or like wow
this is cool and and it's like nobody
can say
whether or not they're right or wrong in
their opinion of that like
that's always been what's the most
beautiful thing about artemy is that
it can be perceived in so many different
ways there's not like a set formula to
determine
what is a good art piece and what is a
bad art piece i'm saying those charcoal
dicks
me coming from a musical background
believe me like there would be [ __ ] i
would hear and i'd be like that's
objectively [ __ ]
like that is terrible [ __ ] music
that's terrible songwriting
terrible production but yet they might
find
an audience for it and and who am i then
like
to to look at that and [ __ ] on that and
say that's objectively [ __ ]
no all i can say is that's subjectively
[ __ ] to me to me that's [ __ ]
but you know what if somebody else finds
value in that
bro right i don't i crack the [ __ ] up
there's like these group of like
influencers right um whatever her name
is is like leanne leann b
and she started showing off her art and
this is like a very beautiful girl right
let me tell you something her art is the
shittiest thing i've ever seen in my
life
like i'm talking about she gets she like
taped up a piece of board and spray
painted it like gold put gold flakes it
looks
it looks like cheap [ __ ] that you would
find at t.j.maxx right
but because she has a huge influence
people are like you're so talented right
right i can't believe you created this
and i'm
literally dying laughing because i'm
like these kids are dumb as [ __ ]
yeah like how can you and i think she
sold it for like ten thousand dollars
i mean that's the thing though it can be
like really a self-fulfilling prophecy
of like let's let's say for example
somebody like g-dragon
right he's a huge [ __ ] name in the
k-pop world i mean
the biggest right he's known throughout
the world
and he's known to be an art collector he
loves art he loves collecting it
he has he has a pretty dope collection
of [ __ ] actually
then that leads him into being
a creator himself i mean he already is a
creator for like music but then into
like creating his own art
right just because of his name value and
the fact that he
likes fine art pieces now already makes
him
like a legitimate artist even though
like i might look at that piece and
think like
oh i don't know what the hell is so good
about that but because of his name value
because of his interest in art because
of his collection it's like validates
him as like this guy
knows and so by uh association
he's a great artist you know and the
pieces that he makes
are valuable you know what i mean yeah
so yeah it's it's like
it's so it can be a self-fulfilling
prophecy in that way of like
kind of leveraging your audience or your
fan base
and just kind of connecting yourself to
that and being like yeah
i am talented look at me i know what art
is because look i have millions of
dollars worth of
fine art so how can i not know what good
art is
and so if i make my own [ __ ] obviously
it's good i have fine taste
i need to start drawing stuff or doing
something digitally
i used to use paint really well yeah i
like good stuff
yeah i used to
oh my god now you know what i think like
one of the coolest things is though of
like this nft movement
is that all these people who've created
these legendary memes throughout the
the course of the internet right now
they can authenticate
their original file you know yeah and
and basically
make money off of that because that
thing has been disseminated across the
web
millions and millions of places yeah
like the the
the artists who created the nan cat
absolutely
i saw that like 600k yeah i saw that
yeah and um
yeah so like basically like something
that has developed cultural
currency like social currency and
relevance like has value and yeah
people can come out and just like
actually sell it yeah could you imagine
like
all these artists too now like it's like
eve like even
popular children's books you know like
the the illustrator who created all that
other stuff
like they have they'll have like like
the nft token for the first
book it's like well here this is how
cool is that dude
or even like an original sketch for an
idea right like
this is the original sketch that i i did
to create
yeah yeah popular characters because i
see a lot of value in that like for me
anyways like i would
love something like that right yeah so
even if they did that for i don't know
like an old like dr seuss piece
right that'd be [ __ ] crazy to me and
even like you know
for example like take the the person who
whoever it is who created the floss
dance you know
kids are lit that's literally the most
popular dance yeah you know like
because they're doing it left and right
and like imagine if that person comes
and like actually like does it
him or herself and like tokenizes it
yeah you can
which is um this actually kind of
coincided with me
learning about and how to do the
philosophy
but nba top shot right yeah yeah yeah i
did not realize
that that was nfts oh yeah yeah and then
i saw that scene blowing up because a
friend of mine introduced me to it
and then he was like dude i you know i
just spent like a thousand dollars over
the past like month and a half
so nba top shots are digital basketball
cards
holy [ __ ] okay or digital clips that are
cards
right i call them moments yeah moments
right and so it might be like
let's say lebron duncan on somebody it's
like a 10 second clip
but that clip now has nft
to make it unique and now you own that
moment in nba history
and that because of that it becomes very
valuable
so like he was like dude i spent like a
thousand dollars
over the past month and a half just
buying these uh nba top shot packs
and um in in a like two weeks it was
worth like 10 grand
and then in about four weeks was worth a
hundred grand his portfolio
of [ __ ] that he had and so in a span of
a month he [ __ ]
100x you know what the [ __ ] man
and then so when i was looking at it i
was like okay i can see
how digital basketball cards can be like
this hype trend type of [ __ ]
and it's hot for a quick minute and gone
but then that was before i realized it
was nfts
uh yeah yeah once i realized it's nfts i
said
okay now it's making a lot more sense to
me well how did he get his hands on
these like no you just nbatopshot.com so
you just buy them yeah i tried to get in
releases today
like i i failed every release yeah it's
so hard yeah
i got into late and i tried and then the
site that's at the
the time the site was just crashing yeah
and but they did create a good system
yeah it's basically you join the drop
at a certain time and then you get a
random place in the queue
and then let's say they have 60 000
packs available
um and you get assigned like 33 000 then
you're gonna be able to get a chance to
buy that
like once your time your your place in
line comes up you get like a 30 minute
window to make the purchase wow but then
if you're like number 120 000 just
forget it leave the line you're not
gonna
you're not getting it right yeah um but
then yeah
i realized that they uh
those were nfts and and so like what you
just talked about like the dance
becoming
tokenized right it is is really that
it's like you can take the
even the original clip of like the dance
i have a gift of me going around on
twitch
of me topping dollar bills oh that's
true i've seen this
[ __ ] hey
you can but then the thing is though who
you didn't create that though so
they created that gift of you how dare
they think
because you could you could reach out to
the person yeah split
parallels i was like hey you can't you
can't own my face dude
that's not how it works but yeah it's
it's like when i think about all of
those things it's just [ __ ]
mind-blowing for you man because it's
like
all right me and you we we've obviously
grew up
collecting basketball cards and yeah you
know those are so valuable
shout outs to my mom who gave away my
pokemon cards
who that are [ __ ] worth like hundreds
of thousands of dollars
she gave to some little [ __ ] korea oh
that little [ __ ] i hated that little kid
too
i came back from college and i was like
hey where in my car she goes oh i gave
it to that kid i was like i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you
i literally showed a picture of the card
that i had
because it was like one of those it was
when pokemon cards first dropped
and i the very first pack i ever opened
had a
had a first edition charizard oh this is
when i was this is when i was like
what's six years old
yeah that's six figures easy right easy
and i took care of
i've never i put it in the little
plastic thing in a hard case and i never
touched it because i was very meticulous
with that [ __ ] yeah
and she i had by the way i had two of
them and she gave both
all of them away wow to some kid who was
like this [ __ ] kid that her parents
are [ __ ] bajillionaires
like what the [ __ ] did you give it i
showed my mom that when it was worse she
goes oh i made a mistake i'm like yes
you made a big mistake that collection
would have changed your life
yes stop sucking dick for money
oh my god damn you had two charizards i
had two
do i had i had every the original pack i
had every [ __ ] card in first edition
[ __ ] no man that's
crazy that's crazy because i hated when
it like any
like there would be a ruffle or some
kind of scrap on it or whatever
so i moment i took it out yeah i had him
numbered individually in a binder
and the hollow ones were in the hard
case though yeah i love you mother
you know speaking of nfts i actually
have a jordan autograph card
that had a certificate of authenticity
to verify that it's real right
but i lost that certificate of
authenticity when i was a kid
so you know unless i get it
authenticated again
that signature really doesn't have value
on that card yeah the card itself might
have some value but then that signature
doesn't increase that value unless it's
authentic right
now we get to offset that problem of
just having a qr code a scannable code
to verify it instantly yep yeah
so all this [ __ ] man that's happening
like crypto kitties
they're the same guys who made me a top
shot yeah
and i and i found out about that company
and then they made their own
cryptocurrency and i was like holy [ __ ]
dude
that thing i feel like is going to blow
up you know with the way
like that that whole movement has been
going
but i find out u.s citizens can't
purchase it and i was like
yeah yeah i was like what the [ __ ] is
this you know i was trying to buy it at
like
uh i think twenty dollars you know now i
think it's trading at like 35
38. i'm like why why are u.s citizens
always getting shafted out of [ __ ] like
this man
yeah if you if you had advice for
somebody who wanted to get into
purchasing nft what do you what do you
suggest like first of all how do you buy
buy this art where do you buy it at um
so a lot of the times you
well nba top shops you can use your
credit card yeah so if you're like you
know in
nba maybe you might want to buy some
packs because it's kind of fun yeah you
know you just buy some packs they're
like think like one nine books or
something yeah and it ranges anywhere
from like nine
ten twenty depending on like yeah yeah
yeah yeah um so that would be a good
place if you're like you know you know
into nba or want to get into
nba um but a big issue right now is that
a lot of
the the nice nfts are like really
expensive
and we i i don't want that a lot of
people don't want that like
we want this to be something that
everyone can participate in you know
and um you know on nifty gateway they've
really
they've really done well um but a lot of
the pieces are now like
minimum like 500 right um right
maybe a little bit less yeah it's like i
and i saw it it's a huge barriers entry
you know yeah
i saw that like you have to apply as an
artist if you want to sell your stuff on
there yeah it's really hard to
have that prove you you know and so that
pretty much means
yeah if you got a following we'll we'll
you know sell your [ __ ] if you're a
nobody
tough luck buddy yeah it's like it's
tough
um but they're really going for kind of
like the the
following yeah yeah i didn't i
thought it was like fine because like i
i really just wanted everyone to start
to know about this because two two
months ago really nobody right he knew
right
um now that's kind of changing so like
it's inevitable
with it like within the next six years
like literally every single person's
gonna
like hear like nfc just like everyone's
now now
like thinks crypto is like kind of legit
you know
um but yeah like to answer your question
like getting into it um
it's a it's a big barrier to entry right
now and i hope
it's gonna move forward but like right
now um you kind of have to have
cryptocurrency
um the main currency the main crypto
that people use to buy
um these pieces is ethereum it's either
because ether actually made right like
possible right right it's it's basically
off of
their technology right yeah yeah and
so
uh there's there's gonna be progress to
try to like make it
accessible um but right now it's not and
it's it's kind of unfortunate and that's
why that's also part of the reason why i
made this grants program because
actually to create an nft is like a
hundred dollars
be just because of the cost of the net
to use the network yeah in the past it
was not like this
but because of how much activity is
happening on the ethereum network it's
just becoming like more expensive to use
and so like you know a creation of an
nft a mint
is can range from like 50 to 150
depending on the current network usage
and so like that's a huge barrier for
entry for people who want to
kind of sell their art right like it's
huge yeah especially if you're a
struggling artist
you know yeah and like you know if
you're not really familiar with crypto
it's
really kind of scary you know and so
there's got to be ways to really kind of
like ease people in and to really have
more have opportunity for themselves you
know
and so yeah it's tough right now um
what i hope though is that like this
doesn't just become
like a fad or like a trend or even worse
it there's longevity with it but it
becomes
only accessible to the elite you know
because that's always been the most
ironic thing about art
it's the poorest people who are creating
these pieces
that the richest people are buying up
you know that that finds value to the
richest and wealthiest people
and as a result it becomes only reserved
for the
elite the one percenters two percenters
um whereas the everyday people really
have zero access to that world
yeah and it's gonna be different i'm
like look at like nba top shots yeah you
know like if you had bought them for
nine bucks each that's yeah that's kind
of accessible but right
now like if if you had bought it early
yeah you would have made like so much
money right and it's and it's really
happening a lot of people
have did take that step kind of like
invest in themselves
uh and put their art out there and
people's lives are changing across the
world yeah like
because they couldn't have they couldn't
have gotten this money otherwise you
know and it's it's
it's awesome yeah and i'm sure like more
and more platforms are gonna pop
up right like for example you have sites
like behance.net
where it used to just kind of be a
digital portfolio for these artists to
showcase their stuff
but maybe it can become a marketplace
now right like yeah
people would find gigs because people
would find their art and then
contact them to hire them for a gig but
then now if you can also be have it be a
portfolio of
your work and work that's for sale that
could be very valuable for just to
everyday sorry i got my
my my logo for my [ __ ] oh there you go
that [ __ ] was expensive as [ __ ]
actually it was so [ __ ] expensive it
was
well because i wanted to buy for the
logo i wanted to buy artwork for it
right
and there's this guy that i follow and
i'm like i'm going to see how much this
[ __ ] costs right
i mean i for a logo people spend like
100 couple hundred bucks
but then i was for him he was an artist
so i was like how much does it cost it's
like 3 500
i was like oh my god but i really like
his work
you know and he created a custom piece
for this yeah for this podcast
you know i don't regret it that's cool i
was like hey bro make the nft for me
because i [ __ ] that's mine
you know right it's amazing right you
know
well hey man uh what do you want to plug
before you sign out
um well i guess i already kind of
plugged my grants program
um uh is that is that just for like
inspiring artists yeah like if you're if
you're like a digital artist
um aspiring artist and you want to
really get into the space
um we're actually closing applications
on the seventh
um so you could just literally just
submit your artwork that's something
that you know you really like and you
want to
you want it to be your first mint and um
hey let's draw a bunch of penises
tonight in this
man we're gonna get the knife so fast
you said on twitter is where they could
find mostly where you do most of your
communication anyways right yeah like
the whole like nfc community
twitter is the the most exciting twitter
uh my twitter is uh
illist ill est raider r-a-t-e-r
then underscore because apparently
someone thought of that before
yeah and then and then the site again
for your your foundation and that's a
grand style art
brands dot art yeah and i'm just really
excited for that so
i think it could really help and change
people's lives so
yeah yeah i mean this this is like
exciting man it's really exciting to
like
learn about it at i i don't want to say
infancy stage
exactly but it's still kind of there
yeah for sure yeah
cool there's a lot of opportunity yeah
well that wraps up this episode you guys
can find
the genius brain podcast every thursdays
and sundays
uh you can find ed at uh edric ed2
i keep saying that you guys [ __ ]
aaron no too many ads dude all right
i'll speak for myself you can find me at
n2 instagram secret society also
cop the gear uh brain 15 15
off for first time customers yep and
we'll see you all next time peace peace